danger what is going on with them
without we're doing this does this
anxiety thing and I can't
it's me anxiety
quietly and Islam kind of just it's just
I can see it out of the corner of my eye
any bugs and I know what your anxiety I
don't know what your feeling anxiety but
right now can we talk about it yeah I'm
good I'm good I was just very quiet for
like a half an hour so I just I have to
do something with my no you don't got to
get it out I put it in my index page Rex
this is your check
[Music]
andrew does I gave him an anxiety
blanket the other day because Pete Lee
gave me for my dress on Instagram the
really heavy blanket heavy in an x-ray
it feels like a light dead man is on top
of you a dead man with Lake cancer
standing is laying on top of Stan when
Andrew talks about or fight like
Joey bitch let's make this easier what
do you like about it
Tora unfurling this yeah usually she
breaks down oh my I don't have people in
my life who are just only irritate me so
he he brings a lot to my life he so far
by the way from the inside because he
does feel at times when he's not anxious
he feels like a support animal to me he
will sue Andrew that was a compliment he
feels like a and because when I spike in
my anxiety that's when he gets super
chill and he will he will counteract
whatever I'm feeling but when I'm to
chill sometimes he gets anxious and I
can't have an act like it doesn't yeah
and and it would be fine if you were
paying me but so can I ask a question
yeah are you gonna get a chip put in him
in case
he does put a little red cape on me
we'll get on the plane she's gonna give
me to her mom soon I would love to give
you to my mom you just every once a
while check in on me love that you would
like me more if I was in st. Louis you
would actually like think about me more
you owe me like hate oh I sometimes like
oh I wonder how he is but I think I'd be
okay I don't know I don't think you get
by I honestly you do bring a ton to my
life you're one of my best friends
you're my road companion you are so
funny no one's funnier than Andrew Colin
like on the fly you point a camera at
him when I post on stories if you're
listening and you watch my stories
Andrew doesn't need second takes he is
always funny I never have to erase a
video when I put it on him he is a
hundred percent funny all of the time he
makes me laugh all the time when he
keeps it light the other day he was like
kind of in his phone and I go yo you
need to be like stop being antisocial
like you need to be funny around me
right now cuz I need your energy of
funniness also known as dance monkey
[Music]
you're on your phone so much that I
don't know when you want my dance I'll
tell you don't you dare ruin this for me
there's a new show on vh1 love and set
times all I have Karen you know that
brings great stories to my life I'm not
out there hooking up a time like I
thrive on his like fun hookup stories I
think that's really fun he's also so
nice like he'll always build me up he
thinks of good ideas for my career he
was the one to suggest to me that I go
do Tom Segura's podcast Burt Chryslers
podcast Theo Vaughn's podcast which led
me to have hundreds of thousands of new
followers all
andrew was like hey when we come back
from the road he could just go back home
to Brooklyn but instead he comes to my
place and you'll carry he'll help me
carry my bags on the flights of stairs
and then he'll spend the night on my
couch and I honestly want him to because
I get scared after watching the Ted
Bundy tape I don't like being a single
girl alone so it's nice to have like
someone for Ted Bundy the murder first
on the favor of staying the night a lot
of times is sleeping on my couch
uncomfortably yeah some would say that
maybe I'm doing him a favor by letting
him crash in Manhattan for the night but
actually I I like when you're there
because I and you know that I need that
obviously and you know I won't murder
you because I'm too lazy yes you won't
murder eat me you won't molest me you
won't do anything weird he's just a
really good friend and also you put up
with a ton of abuse and I appreciate in
front of people she's different behind
the other day because he was nap in the
morning before you get your coffee
that's like your big time that's like
your time to like really shine the other
day to pick up my phone which was broken
cuz he was gonna take it to get repaired
while it's going to do Nick viols
podcast Nick Viall by the way it has a
podcast I'm on it it's called vile files
it drops today check it out but I was
going to record that my phone wasn't
working I said Andrew can you come over
in ten minutes I was there in 20 minutes
later I was 15 minutes away I didn't
shower I ran out I got there he acts as
my assistant because I pay
I'm not complaining right it might sound
like complaining he gets there he gets
to my hotel room and I'm trying to like
figure out everything get dressed and
get ready I'm kind of like rushing I'm
not in a great mood he's there and it
was really nice of you to zip over there
so quickly like that was awesome you
were like such a hero in that moment but
then I turn around and he's eating one
of my protein bars there's 45 bars
there's 45 45 45 doesn't mean I didn't
pay for those 45 bars I skip breakfast
to get to you ask first ask first I go
is that did you just did you ask and he
goes to give me that voice I'm just and
that was all I was because but again I
was projecting because often times when
I have friends that have an abundance of
things but you've given me open reins to
the protein bars in many other settings
yes so then this setting where I thought
I came in I'm the hero
I deserve maybe a little protein you
weren't wrong you weren't wrong but I I
rotated me so much to see you just
gnawing on one of my protein bars just
sucking it with my machine ring my own
blender the protein bar in the blender
again these are the good things about I
didn't scream at you I go ask first
just ask next time and then that got us
started on a bad foot for that day and I
take full credit because I was only
projecting because I've been someone who
takes things without asking from my rich
friends Amy Schumer like how this go
into her kitchen
grab whatever the I want because
I'm like she won't notice I don't it's
almost bothersome to be like hey can I
have these chips which she's like yeah
you could have don't like I don't give a
have chips yeah you don't want that
reaction either of asking a person to be
like why are you asking you know I'll
give it to you except for this one time
when I'll make you feel horrible and
then all day I felt so much anxiety yes
okay so then we came back from LA in LA
where we came on Monday we get back he
spends the night Tuesday morning
yesterday morning I woke up early I go
to the gym he's on this couch I come
back and I walk in and you you're but
you at one point hear me like stirring
I'm trying to be quiet to be like so
that you can like sleep through the
morning and you turned on the couch like
you you turned your back to me and
there's a wrapper of a protein bar stuck
to your back stolen the day before and
it was stuck to his back and just kind
of falling like you couldn't have asked
if you would have knocked on my
door today your womanizing in there I
would have hated you even more but I
hated seeing that loose rap take a
picture because it was just the so
sloppy the way it was hanging you guys
realize you're a married couple right
that nobodies yeah all those
factors this is like I'm listening to
the you're doing I'm going I got a
wife two beautiful girls
I barely want to do half that for
her she lets me bang her you know she's
kind enough that no she's doing me a
favor right now letting me bang her
that's why I do all these things
I think everybody's yeah I think your
wife is messing up by yeah
I'm so I do acknowledge and I talk about
it a lot with my other friends like I'm
really mean to Andrew and I need to pull
it back because it I just now you're
fine I don't know you can take it
confronted me about it before I've been
like you're your bitch I don't think
you've said that but you're right I'm a
bitch to you sometimes and it's because
I I don't I don't know why and I'm
working on it I want to tell you that
and currently I'm not working on it like
this like this David Spade and that
ended just fine okay so don't worry I
told you I would kill her but I just
went too lazy to get rid of the body
I don't know what I would the fourth
story worked yeah murdered someone we
were talking about like how I go how
would you dispose with the saliva he
would just drown I would not burn a
condom with her well my mom had to
put topical cream on me like 45 I had to
open it up mom vaginal fusion
vaginal fusion when didyou was with sex
really painful for you at first yeah
yeah it took me like two I'm my for my
high school boyfriend like I tried to
have sex like three times I could never
I didn't lose my virginity until I was
in college
Wow oh my god you ever take a running
start I didn't break my hymen to lay I
slept with my hip-hop teacher when I was
in college it upset do you know that you
are right now on the top ten
like trending searches on pornhub I did
you know that I know what did you just
see that on your no no somebody told me
that Monday night I was like oh my god
so weird
you don't love it yeah I love it but I
wish I had some content on there I don't
know what they're looking for their arms
so jealous
oh it's after your Conan so I bet you
had something to do Thanks
you do a show every month called stand
up and take your clothes off yeah you
get full-on no no no I hire burlesque
acts
okay I'm Santa comics and then I have
burlesque acts they get naked
I'll flash a terrifying my period I I
love you on Instagram because you you've
got it and you fall on it you are hot on
Instagram and I'm oh I respect that so
much because I would like to be hot on
Instagram and me let her know there's
some
get out of the shower and I want to like
yeah you do like you will be Oh
semi-nude master grammar because you've
girl you've got you have got it and I
and I appreciate what I see it I'm never
judgmental of it I'm like I wish I could
do that what what how can you do that
when you here's here's my dilemma when I
post something that is just like I look
hot right now is that other comedians
are gonna screenshot it and then text it
to each other like Glaser think she's
hot what's funny about this picture
what's funny about that
all she wants his male attention yeah
she it's not about the joke 82% my
answer is her man sorry and then they
come all over their phone and they stop
talking about male comics I'm worried
about yeah and those fellows have
dropped off and that's fine like yeah
like I don't know oh you see you know
what my friend Kelsey cook also posted a
picture where she was like pretty nude
in it but she was saying like I'm owning
it like she had this whole statement
about and she said she lost so many
flowers because yeah I posted something
that was a little bit oh yeah sometimes
I think it's like guys that are married
or in relationships and their
girlfriends see and they're like oh
sorry about that
[Music]
it's weird I'm just like I'm an
alcoholic right so like my new drinks
know I haven't had a drink in nine
months but I relapsed minute I have a
tattoo that says don't serve me you've
seen me drunk yeah oh cool a second you
talk to me about this shitty tattoo okay
dancer script it's beautiful I relate to
so much of what you're saying I want to
just back up a little bit yeah when did
you first get sober um probably when I
was like like probably five six years
ago I've gotten like two and a half
years and then I relapsed for six month
two and a half years relapse for a year
okay and now I'm nine months how were
these relapses because I love relapse
for a year like that's not of real it's
like a new life she's taking her time
I realize for nine years in the died of
old age because I'm seven seven and a
half years and right and just drinking I
smoke weed but I smoke weed okay so
neither of your silver yeah I have to be
very like I do not drink but I do not
consider myself sober by any means I
just announced I'm an alcoholic who
doesn't drink yes right now but I
believe in marijuana management even
though a doesn't yeah that's my problem
with a that people don't feel
comfortable going back there when
they're smoking weed I mean they really
need support so in there they feel
ostracized because they're doing this
other dangerous they say it in the
beginning of every meeting if you've
taken any mood elevators you're not
allowed to share you I got stone to
tell you my story
yeah don't share you're there for 35
minutes going eating munchkin Taco Bell
with this story let you to have these do
can you pinpoint what led you to relapse
because there are times where I go I
could just have one drink right yes I
mean yeah I'm like a textbook alkie in
that sense where like my brain does work
that way it's just have like a $15.00
glass of Sauvignon Blanc
it's like expensive you'll just have one
and then cut to you like a month later
I'm doing shots of tequila before I go
to work right it's insane yeah so you
really it's like textbook like I'm like
a snowball type of and it gets worse
every relapse but in it like I also I've
fallen on my head I got eight stitches
on my forehead and like a while ago this
is like your karate chop you in the neck
but yet but so like push you do seem to
happen after breakups but I don't it's
not even like I'm so sad like I missed
that guy it so this is a great excuse
when you get out of a breakup you're
single again meeting guys and hooking up
and all of that is so wrapped up in
drinking totally and when you're dating
and you don't drink it's weird
totally find it weird
and it is weird because it's hard to
become intimate with someone for the
first time when you don't have that
lubrication drinking so that makes sense
why you would kind of ease back into it
when you're newly single totally so you
so you had some bad bottoms where oh
yeah was the stitches about where you go
I need to quit that was a bottom yeah
and then that was like my first time
like not drinking for two and a half
years and then I got banned from the
stand oh yeah I called Patrick billing
in a fat f-word to his face for you he
did he just like I just started getting
paid spots again they're not good for
you and he goes he goes you're the first
person who's been banned has gone from
band to paid like come back the power of
alcohol makes you a bad person and when
you remove it then you're exactly and
funny Trump's being a drunken asshole
that's it actually yeah when your comic
we are in the audience never that's okay
so you so you were talking about there
was something else that was oh so now
when you're sober you get addicted other
things good I very much relate to yeah
and you say that working out now it's
kind of like an addiction what what's
your I'm an equinox every day I'll tame
any of the classes I'm not very
disciplined like I see you you're like
disciplined like you can like run and
like be on your own and do stuff great I
need to be in a group setting like
competing with others like I need a
couple of fat Asians behind me to feel
good and like I got my pump on I'm
addicted to working out right now too
because not because I'm trying to like
look good it's just like
it's something to do that isn't smoking
weed or sleeping yeah it just makes me
it's something yeah shopping yeah
absolutely the locker room yesterday
though was on fire
with hot girls when I discovered old
rapper back over here talking to you
with rapper on his back sighs I don't
know which bar it is like I'm trying to
figure out which bar it could be there's
like so many back there
so I told Andrew I was like dude there
was a girl in the locker room that was
so do you ever get in locker room and
yeah I am so lucky right now men would
kill to be surrounded by these hips by
these perfect tips these actions
everywhere it's just like you two
villages are preparing the fish
yesterday
I'm not joking you she was in I don't
want to say stockings not stockings
pleased leggings yeah like that you get
in an egg like one of like oh okay it's
sheer black leggings and a really short
skirt with the leggings were up to here
in a short skirt topless right no top
just brushing her hair her makeup look
so hard because I was so I was so turned
off there I can't help myself here's how
I see I have a trick when you're
blow-drying your hair yeah put your head
through your legs
see below line-of-sight see looking you
have the whole seringai know then you're
giving I'm a girl who just I at least
wear a bra I'm not one of these girls
that goes just top like you don't need
to blow-dry your hair without a shirt on
I do I actually do it because I swear
sweater I'm a huge hole or something
yeah I have my boobs I'm not mad about
my boobs so they're finally no bother
you buddy they're small keep making that
face you know I would die to be when you
guys crawl on the table but I check out
women I'm like I'm like where do they
get these hips sometimes like I'm hip
'less wake I'm like their bodies are not
you know hips I'm like how do they do it
they're Jewish
Andrew your asshole your heart nipples
just make my dick just rock-hard I can
come on your bald head stood up and his
balls were just dangly and skin and I
live I feel grateful for working at it
the level of hotness both in LA because
I go to LA ones and New York is insane
and I'm like guys would kill to see how
I'm killing right now and I tried it
like capture it in my mind and and maybe
I'm trying to get kicked out of Equinox
by saying that ice that's the only way
to get out of your contract it still
like a breakthrough I'm trying to put it
out there you know what also use Equinox
for to shave my puss hell yeah I guess I
don't Nick to my tape the other day in
there oh my god it stung when I peed
that's when you just like cut your labia
like use I go I go I love amenities I
let my hair grow out pretty intensely
when I'm not hooking up and then I feel
an impending hooking up chance when I
shave it all off and that's a lot of
cleanup in your bath because once it's
there's a ring of hair well it looks
like you it's a lot of clean and I
rushed that on Equinox I suck back you
ever do this for the longest no no more
[Laughter]
guys I'm outta here I gotta go jerk off
see you at Equinox you're watching the
outtakes with Nikki and Andrew are you
using this loss okay you share that with
people that is a bag that you go do one
I mean I used to do with dog bags this
isn't the time to brag about other bags
you use is the time to be like this
never happened anything could be floss
anything can be floss yeah when you have
a gap in your teeth like you had your my
god Noah has chosen she went through
them all for me because I did not want
to judge yeah you don't like doing those
no I don't so these are the ones we've
selected and we just have to pick which
ones go where one for like reception so
what do you want people to like you when
they walk in when they walk in here yeah
okay so let's look for that one I'm
dying for your input no you're not you
hate it no I am this is actually
interesting to me that's too hot that's
like if I was coming out with like a yes
I don't think about you type thing I get
it like you should do something outside
your comfort zone like what people don't
expect I get that so what are we looking
for what do you thinking that is my vibe
oh I'll find it no no no what I was
running out how many I did you do keep
going oh why is it that my vibe why
isn't why isn't that my vibe I just
think it's like too much of a smile is
too big of a smile I'm a happy person
are you
yes that is the vibe of the show we are
huh yeah that's fine I like that that is
me laughing it I like that more than the
other ones okay
No
I like that that's the one I like that
one the best because that's fun it's
also sexy it's like I don't know I like
that one the way you say sexy couldn't
be said sexy sexy laughs yeah say it
again it doesn't I can see it on your
tongue it's like a film up yeah I have
I've learned to brush my tongue though
this year mm-hmm that just got to you
that news that I had no idea right you
brush your tongue yeah I do a way fight
when my breath to smell extra fresh I
like that one and that one
these are my choices what do you think
so we're Lanie not want to put them in
one for reception we need podcast art
and then we have to refresh all our
socials okay okay I guess like three
different pictures out of these okay so
reception I think should be this because
who cares why don't I just look happy
I'm pretty all my bosses are walking
around here that's who's gonna see it
Howard Stern might see this yeah I'll be
like she's seeing I like it you look fit
this could be good for like I'm honestly
I'm trying to think now what would
Howard Stern one yes what let's take
that way that one is strong wait that
one I think that was that's that's good
that one okay yes that's I have a good
eye
believe it or not I think I have a good
eye that was good yeah this one this one
for for Howard for our banner and then
podcast is that one and then what did we
need something else weren't socials
socials I think that for social yeah
thank you
yeah if you want it to be worse do you
want me to like really pick apart the
picture
yeah go no I wouldn't then let's do it
huh
go hard on one okay no hard on these
thank you
what's wrong with this no first of all
your your thumb is in your belt loop
yeah that's cool that's a cool look how
many people have you met ever that but
their thumb and their belt Lou so many
models that's a thing oh I'll do it
right now it's a comfortable oh yeah
you're gonna jump on this no way the
whole time all right okay I don't know I
don't like doing this this is not this
is not what could you say nothing bad
every piece of confidence I think you
are great
okay what is the what face you I don't I
don't know just you say I don't want to
it's no no no no no I don't think no way
you know well don't be the meanest to be
honest okay oh I can't do it huh
I don't like I have like the tallest
stomach there's no stomach issue that
you could there's no time to get you the
bellybutton is kind of interesting my
bellybutton is awesome you could say
whatever you want you could have any
opinion about my bellybutton
it is awesome I think this is great
what's wrong with nothing what's nice is
yours I just feel like a belly button
coming like just like showing the
midriff it just is this entrance is too
much it's like a little mud yeah I agree
with you that it's too much it's
ridiculous if I was you wouldn't right
it would just be hair with skin coming
over I'm gross bellybutton is and I'm
not one of them if I have anything I
have gross oh so many thing I think when
it's just a belly bun I think if it was
like an abeyance I'm not gonna zoom this
isn't gonna be our instagrams
but this accentuate Stu belly button
because it's only eye I see so much
belly buying here because it's all you
belly button what
let's do a crescent belly button I'm
gonna get a text later what's
wrong with my belly button I know
literally is perfect it's a nice belly
button I'm just gonna say it like
Andrews probably not used to seeing your
belly button
so he's like honed in on it yeah and
maybe it's wintertime Thank You Noah I
know that like you have a different
perspective but no I appreciate like
move over Taylor thank you
move over taylor dayne maybe belly
button
Andrews learning computers remember this
thing in the middle here yeah like my
keyboard clip oh there we go now see it
again as people what it is it looks like
a drawing you got to stitch that up that
needs stitches
yeah that looks clean shave like they
can't see the button what is this yeah
what looks like an empty eyeball yeah it
does look like it looks like a twig it
looks like a that looks like what my
penis look like the other day when the
doctor threw up
[Laughter]
that's what your penis looked like just
the side of it click on the balls area
we zoom in on anything closely it's
gonna be back yeah I agree with that
yeah I'm with you on that like even on
just a slight zoom in on you makes it so
if you solve all my blackheads take a
picture of my nose right now the fact
that you let us do that to you was
really nice thank you yeah it's quite a
sacrifice it was well worth it I mean
I'm going to use that zoom in of your
face for so many different purposes
you